en 15 ans le nombre d'habitants de plus
de 60 ans sein de la communauté urbaine
grand paris seine et oise a augmenté de
30% face à ce constat le groupe vivalto
santé a choisi de regrouper l'hôpital
dumont garder le centre cardiologique
des vêtements à aubergenville le nouveau
site sortir à l'horizon 2024 sur un
terrain de 20 mille mètres carrés
appartenant à la communauté urbaine est
assis particulier la clinique sera ici à
cet emplacement là et puis nous avons
bien entendu nécessité d'offrir aux
patients et aux professionnels de santé
un véritable parking un lieu d'accueil
pour les véhicules nous avons et sommes
nous on la station de bus et froid le
deuxième arrêt au départ de la gare donc
toutes les commodités seront là mais
cette annonce est un coup dur pour la
commune des vêtements pour moi c'était
une surprise je l'appris donc par le
maire d'aubergenville
qui m'a prévenu sous conseils de son
fait prime à la sénatrice nous demandons
basque avec mon ils sont bien le courant
qu'est la clinique va fusionner avec
celle de berre c'est dommage forêt
répond parce que nous sommes là depuis
259 et à près de deux cents lits donc
c'est quand même une clinique qui tourne
en a de mémoire je retourne 5000
patients qui passent par an donc oui ça
fait quand même
du trafic ça fait du volume dans la
villa joint le groupe vivalto santé le
troisième acteur hospitaliers privés
français et cette clinique dans le
département des yvelines sa volonté
renforcer significativement l'offre de
soins dans le nord des yvelines il y
aura aussi de vraies dimensions des
d'amélioration des circuits déficience
même de la prise en charge limiter les
transferts inter établissements
mutualisé aussi tous nos plateaux
techniques on est vraiment aussi sur
cette dimension de recherche de
l'efficience de nos organisations mais
c'est aussi pour nous l'occasion de
permettre aussi une activité en tout cas
un lieu d'exercice qui sera amélioré et
modernisé pour nos équipes avec un total
de 258 la future clinique concentrera
des prises en charge lourdes comme la
cardiologie la pneumologie ainsi que des
soins critiques elle permettra également
de nourrir la coordination entre les
différentes disciplines médicales